this video is sponsored by book Walker
well we've reached the end of 2019 and
once again we get to look back on
another year of anime we got to see all
kinds of shows in all shapes and forms
so that begs the question what are you
gonna remember
[Music]
20:19 a somehow ecord or maybe even
eclipse the monster year that was 2018
ma is good now it's just good and with
more of it than ever before we have not
been struggling for choices without the
goods the bad the ugly and just the
plain weird as we'll take a look back at
what we watched and probably what we
missed let's see how anime signed itself
off for this decade
this is anime in 2019 I'm gonna be
honest with you even I had trouble
keeping up with all the anime coming out
last year and I feel that's just kind of
the norm nowadays so instead of trying
to cover everything I'm just gonna keep
it to my personal favorite things ending
it on my anime of the year but I'll do
my best to talk about everything that
mattered to me and made waves in our
community and looking back for a place
to start in 2019 there was one thing we
kept having to ask ourselves over and
over again are you excited for Maury
Sakai next season you're joking
not another one one of these days I'll
get to look back on the year of anime
and think to myself man there was a
reasonably conservative amount of Issa
KY this time this year wasn't one of
them somehow the number doesn't seem to
be decreasing but increasing every time
I say to myself surely we can't get even
more Issa KY next year no that is a trap
don't say it as soon as you do some
unsuspecting victim tries to cross the
road and truck Cooney claims another
life and nobody can stop it so I'm just
gonna stop doing it I'm not going to
think about it I'm just not going to say
it anymore
alright and this isn't even a dig at the
genre this year we saw more variation
than the usual power fantasy affair that
were used to cautious hero can when
Ameche an descendants of a bookworm all
the genuinely good and different I just
kind of hid my Easter Chi quotes oh I
haven't gotten around to watching them
yet but the world a lot of mothers I did
enjoy non-god on ok meat item shield
here a kicked off the year proven that's
all it takes to make a community
collectively forget about years worth
the built-up east Chi fatigue was one
raccoon girl and an angry boy the serie
sported easily the most hateful villain
of the year that built up to a climax so
satisfying the only thing that was
actually rising was the revenge boner
but he felt community-wide my only real
problem was with how cheap me now flew
me was built up by essentially bringing
everyone else down sure you're rooting
for now for you me
he's held up as being the only competent
character by making everyone but him in
his party and absolute [ __ ] useless
idiots so it's really a no-brainer that
you'd end up cheering for him because
he's the only one that seems to have
half a [ __ ] brain cells
still looking forward to season two and
three though sword art online has gotten
to a point where I just genuinely enjoy
it for what it is
this is just fun popcorn entertainment
and exactly why I enjoy ISA car in the
first place
though I do find it funny that all my
favorite parts of sword art online have
conveniently come when Kirito is out of
the picture
Alice taking on the main role has been a
welcome change and have been criticism
that she's just a ripoff from saber from
fates but come on guys I mean she may
look like saber talk like saber act like
saber fight light saber have very
similar looking powers as saber but
she's also at cinder age so I don't see
how she can be a rip off when she's
quite clearly an upgrade Ken gender
Margo was nice Akai that's pretty much
all I remember this by actually
finishing it of course II said I still
ISA karna was plenty of trash which I'll
get back to later but for me the
surprise of the year was ISA Chi quartet
cuz I enjoyed it way more than I
anticipated I thought I would get bored
after two episodes but the character
writing and banter was so on point that
never got old we've gotten to the point
where we can just put a bunch of ISA Chi
characters in an esky world and have
them talk about ISA Chi stuff and it's
just entertaining this is partly because
it just kind of felt like an episode of
kana Sieber with an extended cast which
is probably why I enjoyed it so much I'm
just glad that we finally have our own
adventure cards they may not be able to
avenge the world but you can be damn
sure they'll reincarnate into another
one overall I think the model this year
is that sa Chi is here to stay and is
still definitely thriving and that's
fine because you know what surely we
can't get even more ISA Chi next year
[Music]
he had to say it when I think of the
music that came out of anime in 2019
what comes to mind is I don't have much
to say about the OS T's of this year
sure there was singular songs and tracks
that stood out journos theme Isabelle's
lullabies that track from a scene in
Demon Slayer shout out to my boy Kevin
penguin for looking at your typical
anime fantasy setting and thinking you
know what this needs
sexy ISA Chi saxophone
[Music]
but unlike previous years there weren't
any sound tracks as a whole that really
stood out that is of course until I
realized the best anomie music of the
year was stuck behind Netflix jail one
of them was B stars but the other one
gives me the opportunity to talk about
[Music]
Carolyn shoes they didn't just give us
an OST it just straight-up gave us
several albums worth of music the sheer
amount of songs on display here and all
different genres is absolutely insane
you've got stuff like EDM metal
Carolyn Tuesday simpler acoustic sound
whatever genre this fits into and of
course classic pop I know that was just
a single episode while in most music
anime the show will normally sent around
some musicians building up to their next
big performance their next big song
which if we're lucky will happen maybe
every three four episodes
Carolyn Tuesday she's here casually
debuting at least one new song every
episodes at least once most of the time
we're getting to three or four coming
from the various characters and displays
not forgetting other miscellaneous
things like uh no actual background
music the Opie's the EDS and even
references to the classical music of its
setting in the future my mother passed
away not that long ago I'm singing a
song she often sang to me when I was
young I don't think there's been another
anime that's come close to the amount of
music in this show
and I realize when watching this how
much of a core elements music is in all
of Shinichiro want an Arby's works
because this entire show felt like his
personal love letter to music itself and
I don't think anyone else would have
been able to get so many talented
artists from all over the world to help
provide for music for a single anime if
the writing had been tighter this had
the potential to be an absolute
masterpiece but as it stands it is
simply a good show with by far the most
impressive music production any anime
has ever seen and maybe won't ever guess
cuz I don't know man I don't see how any
show will ever top the likes this
[Music]
[Music]
speaking of which [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
over good if we're going through the
best of anime we also can't forget the
best of the worst we saw so let's do the
rundown of what we got to experience
this year a lot of [ __ ] ISA guys a
lot of softcore hentai not enough
culture number of anime girls this year
who asks someone to drink their urine to
brief a good memories number of anime go
if you saw the suppository get shoved up
their ass this year
I don't it rectally also teen let's see
what magical girls get up to this year
let's forget what magical girls got up
to this year how about shows that acted
as visual bleach for the eyes was kick
things off with an equally ugly sequel
to have shakers absolutely nobody asked
for seven deadly sins and of the year
off from one of the most highly
anticipated fights with the series
Mellie Otis vs. esken or a fight so
hyped up my fans that studio teen tried
to do it justice by staying faithful to
the franchise and adapted it using only
seven deadly frames of animation mister
Nobunaga's young bride gave us an anime
about a lolly attempting to convince a
fully grown man's gets married to her
and consummate it that's it that's the
plot of the show
the worst cg award went to addy faretta
who also gave us the rising of the ghoul
hero the off-brand Christmas presents um
mum probably gave to the poor get was
the shield hero featuring another edgy
protagonist teaming up with a 300 year
old demon lolly
with a romantic subplot they were
totally gonna dangle in front of us oh
and of course there were the two
dumpster flies this year the burn so
brightly I couldn't keep my eyes off
them I watched the master girlfriend
with my girlfriend once she's my
stepsister now domestic girlfriend is
what happens when you take a typical
harem Roma's anime and then try to do a
full 100% degeneracy speedrun and
succeed
a show of so much spice you have to
refer to the Scoville scale when rating
it documenting the case of a protagonist
who finally dropped the mister and got
with his sister using a secret technique
never before seen in anime Hey want to
be my girlfriend
but we can't we're brother and sister no
please I insist okay I don't even know
why YouTube do you monetize my review of
this I thought domestic girlfriend was
the epitome of family-friendly content
then finally we add assassin's pride
commonly referred to as milady battle
angel a port that was written like a
fanfiction of a fan fiction of an anime
that didn't actually have a better love
story than Twilight meets Kufa vampire
sign of a twisted relationship between a
vampire and a fedora full time lolly
wolly knock-knock what's this a
perfectly suitable romantic interest
who's in love with you and also a
similar age what are you legal this is
Cooper vampyre the FBI I have to check
if they're on the Cooper vampyre
registry when Chris Hanson tells him to
take a seat he's already
and of course he's the only man who
could possibly cap off this year of
glorious trash this year had a strong
showing from slice-of-life of romance
not just giving titles that were solid
additions to the pre-established formula
but also ones that broke the mold and
did something new but he Sookie did too
harem what CONUS Eber had done for ISA
Kai henskee gave us a bunch of new kinks
just so he could shame us later on
Fruits Basket Brotherhood was the thing
I still need to finish people are
terrified right now at the implication
of the world war season 3 teaser / just
got released forgetting that
quintessential quintuplets has already
started world war 5 in 2019 and many of
us have already been drafted sang cusan
was ASMR for the eyes by giving us a
middle-aged salary man mastering the
forbidden technique of dual wielding
head Pat's against some innocent boomer
volleys in what my depression has
categorized as an Avengers level threat
but if I had to talk about the shows
that really had an effect on me the
first one that comes to mind would have
to be cocky a summer oh love me mister
hey mister and one of the most
refreshing takes of the romantic comedy
genre I've seen in a while the mix of
the absurd over-the-top mind games in
the typical harem romance situations was
a premise that continued to be hilarious
throughout and before I knew it I was
actually heavily invested in these two
characters getting together I think
there was another reason to watch a show
but um just can't remember what it was
of course how could I forget
ishigami best girl our maidens in your
savage season was probably my overlooked
gem of the year in one of the most
hilariously accurate portrayals of
puberty I've seen in anime it's rare
they get to see the topic of sex tackled
as the awkward uncomfortable mess that
it is when you first discovered it and
started thinking about it you know that
one embarrassing sex story everyone
seems to have as a teenager that is
hilarious to tell but kind of makes you
want to die inside when you remember it
that is it that is the show how heavy
are the dumbbells you lift finally gave
us cute girls do lifting in an anime so
Alfa not even Tyler one can come close
to even matching it well this might not
be the greatest anime of the year it
certainly had one of the biggest
real-life effects on me because I don't
want to admit that I'm that degenerate
we've got motivated to join a gym
because I saw some cute anime girls
doing it but I'm that degenerate we
become motivated to join the gym because
I saw some cool anime girls doing it
which makes me think what's next for
cute anime girls cute girls do basic
daily hygiene cute girls through filling
out your annual tax return cute girls to
interact with cute girls in real life
whatever it is I think we finally
figured out the end goal of all MOA
shows cute girls through transforming
weaves into functional members of
society and then there was my personal
favorite high school drama of the year I
came in to be stars knowing nothing
ready to meme the [ __ ] out of it and I
came out with one of my favourite anime
of the year this feels like one of the
most unique series in recent memory and
no it's not because the characters are
walking furry mates
this doesn't feel like your typical
glossy anime in fact it doesn't feel
like anime at all it gives off the vibe
of an oscar-nominated film or a highly
acclaimed stage play with the
combination of some of the best voice
acting performances you can find all
here and fantastic direction that was
one of the only times in my life that
had me saying man I'm really glad this
animes in 3d it's the story of a murder
mystery an unequal society dominated by
the strong a man driven to obsession to
be the image of the perfect star and
also a touching love story between a
literal virgin and actual chat the world
of B stars is one that draws you in and
sells you on these
it deeply immerses youth and sells you
on pure drama and emotion it says a lot
that are sure about anthropomorphize
animals was the one that felt most real
you forget that you're watching wolves
rabbits deers and Metal Gear Panda in
fact their animalistic characteristics
are able to emphasize emotion in a way
that makes them seem even more eerily
human and I can't wait to see what the
story will have to offer in season two
and hopefully beyond basically in a
nutshell i watch B stars and I'm still
not a fairy bah
normally in the year of anime we get to
see some high-octane hard-hitting shows
so with that in mind what a 20-19 offer
[Music]
yeah this year was kind of dry as a
whole fer realz o 2019 was one of the
most action-packed years in recent
memory with old and new franchises not
only continuing the expected hype for a
lot of the times reaching their absolute
P Dimas layer blew up the entire
community in a single episode mops like
a hundred showcase some of the most
impressive fight sequences I've ever
seen attack on Titan topped IMDB shot
for the highest-rated episode of any
series of all time and my year academic
did an excellent job at coloring in some
manga panels
they totally made up for it later though
there are several anime of the Year
contenders right here and most of them
could have easily won if they had aired
in any other year so this is going to be
a pretty long segment the star would mop
the first season of mob boys felt like
he was living in the shadow of one punch
man but this was the season it truly
grew into his own and maybe even
surpassed his older cousin what I
expected was more great action more
great animation like the first season
and it delivered that then exceeded it
fights after fight after amazing fight
it was an absolute spectacle for the
group battle against the teleporting
psychic being one of the coolest
sequences I've ever seen but what I
didn't expect was how much heart it
would have as well the character writing
between mob and Regan was phenomenal and
the unexpected character development
they saw and teary moments in the season
sucker punch be way harder than any of
the fights it grew from this flashy
funny action series to something so much
more
it was hype it was emotionally was
touching it was just the complete
package after it finished I didn't think
anything could come close to mobs this
year and then attack on Titan must've
thought that was like yo horde my
kidnapped Eren attack on Titan season 3
part 2 half life 3 platform 9 and 3/4
was the perfect payoff to everything the
series had been building up so far the
legacy of one of the most hyped
franchises to rise up in the past decade
had finally reached that hype than punch
straight past it seeing the evolution of
the series go from thrill ride to
mystery to political thriller to the
culmination of all of this was an
absolute joy to experience the mixture
of a fully developed cast we were all
invested in being put into a high-stakes
situation where you genuinely did not
know what was going to happen resulted
in a dramatic tense action-packed
edge-of-your-seat experienced have
delivered some of the most compelling
entertainment you can find anywhere this
year anime or not it's also one of the
few series that has built up this
massive mystery and actually delivered a
satisfying answer from what I've heard
the events of season four are going to
surpass even this so I am absolutely
hyped I cannot wait properly experience
it for the first time over the coming
year the only way I know how to through
[ __ ] margaritas he can't resist
posting spoilers in the comments section
and then Vinland saga finally broke the
curse of the highly acclaimed historical
seinen manga getting an actual decent
anime adaptation I originally thought
that if villain saga were to ever get an
anime although we need to do is to
animate the manga in a calm
fashion and they will be contender for
anime over the year and that's exactly
what happened
the tale of biking Sasuke on his lone
quest oh okay boomer everything is dad
try to teach him an ASCII chart trying
to set the world record for longest
father killing kill streak in history is
one that will stick with me for a very
long time well it may not be as loud or
in-your-face as some of the other shows
here it hits just as hard or maybe even
more so this is gonna go down as a
special series and with the ending it
gave it was the perfect way to cap off
the year my hero academia has pretty
much continued being my hero academia me
and the boys continued our trip across
Italy nyan JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
golden wind JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
golden wind
[Music]
yes Georgia Popov continued in the
season where Italy itself became a Joe
Joe reference as anime Watchers finally
understood the pain of the question how
the [ __ ] those King Crimson world
fans were finally rewarded with many
highly anticipated moments including the
animated 7 page reader that was a
glorious moment any father would be
proud of next up is
fire for sick the phrase fighting fire
with fire - whole new heights as David
production finally got a chance to flex
their animation muscles outside of Jojo
giving us a show of several choices of
amazing top-tier waifu's and Tamaki yeah
I said her Tamaki fans what are you
gonna do trip over and land on my dick
look I'm a degenerate that lives for
trashy fanservice but there's a time and
a place for that and I don't need it
breaking all the immersion of every
serious action scene she's in finally of
course there was Demon Slayer which was
undoubtedly the new breakout hit this
year I can't remember the last time I
saw such an instant explosion from just
a single episode
see there was Demon Slayer before
episode 19 and then there was Demon
Slayer after episode 19 it went from
this moderately popular action show to
the hip trending topic on Twitter
everyone started watching it and then
ninja tweeted that he was gonna become
the greatest anime of all time and
everyone was like well I mean he's
pretty good at fortnight so it's
probably right not to take anything away
from the scene as I do think it was one
of the most beautifully crafted moments
I've seen in any shown in I mean I kind
of call it a work of art and it is a
really good show but I think as a whole
it's a bit premature because the story
only just feels like it's truly starting
to get going and his competition this
year are shows that have reached their
narrative Peaks well it finds more
interesting is how after all these years
we've kind of got a big three again with
one piece stay where it is Naruto being
replaced by Green Naruto some people
could even argue that Demon Slayer has
just filled that gap for the new
generations Bleach but I'm not gonna be
the one star that shitstorm of a
conversation
before I get to my anime of the year
there are a few more shows that didn't
really belong to any of these categories
but definitely shouldn't be left out
promised Neverland was an engrossing
thriller about a group of children
breaking out of an extremely secure
locked down facility overlooked by
highly intelligent monsters by playing
tag this was some of the most gripping
anime you could find this year aside
from having a completely unique premise
the cat-and-mouse game manages to
deliver a story with so many twists and
turns without ever feeling like they
were forcing it it builds up tension
beautifully and it's one of those
cliffhanger shows that will have you
clicking on the next episode faster than
you could say itadakimasu finally if I
had any small issues with it is that it
pushed my suspension of disbelief to the
[ __ ] limits like I know these kids
are meant to be smart but when they
started playing five d intergalactic
mind games and had already strategized
their highly elaborate scape plan from
the moment they were [ __ ] conceived
all while masking it's as a children's
game I was like I don't know if these
kids could be going that far can they
and if we're still nitpicking there was
something a bit off about how the
characters were drawn but I couldn't
quite put my finger on it
did he just say there was something off
about the way we look yeah I think you
did you say that I don't think there's
anything weird about my face I have a
normal face no you had perfectly normal
what do you think right yeah I have no
idea what the hell he's talking about
meanwhile in dr. stone character designs
it's time dr. stone the share gave us a
long-awaited anime adaptation of those
two Indian guys building huts on YouTube
that somehow got recommended to you at 1
a.m. and I'll be honest this show left
me a bit conflicted in the end on one
hand is one of the most interesting
premises out there and seen the process
of how they make advanced technology
with the most primitive of tools were
some of the most entertaining things you
can find in anime all year but on the
other hand I could give lesser [ __ ]
about any of the conflicts here look I
really don't care that Tsukasa hates
boomers anytime there was a
contractually obligated shounen jump
fight I couldn't help but just want to
go back to seeing the villagers pissing
themselves at the sight of sink you
making glass it's probably the first
time in my life when I've seen a
tournament Arkan I've been like oh
they're putting in a tournament tog yeah
wake me up when something interesting
happened almost single-handedly try
keeping the cyberpunk genre alive long
with Psychopaths giving us an old-school
hard-boiled detective story that
unfortunately got looked over by a lot
of people probably because its name
wasn't something hip and catchy enough
like at that time Alphonse Elric got
reincarnated as a gun Corrado was a
legitimately good remake of a samurai
anime from the 60s there hardly anyone
watched because it was an Amazon Prime
exclusive and the only way I see people
still remembering the show is when they
ask Amazon hey Amazon do you have Demon
Slayer and Amazon Prime and Amazon's
like oh yeah we have Demon Slayer and
Amazon Prime and this is their Demon
Slayer in Amazon Prime push I know Sora
was a very promising anime original
sports drama whose production just got
axed halfway through leaving us once
again with just half an anime fate is
still making more money than they know
how to spend Babylon was a great show
that I apparently missed let's see was
there anything else I left out
[Music]
yeah I think that's everything
this year was honestly the hardest year
to pick my anime of the year for a very
long time I praise 2018 for the sheer
volume of good shows but 2019 has
seemingly matched that while still
producing a handful of shows that were
even better than anything that came out
the year before many of these shows
would have been an easy shoe and if they
literally aired in any other year it was
a tough choice but after dwelling on it
for a week or two I've got to give it to
Finland saga I've said previously that
every so often you come across the work
of fiction like villain saga something
that exudes this sense of unquantifiable
greatness and there is a word that
personifies what I'm talking about a
masterpiece to me Finland saga is a tale
that earnestly earns that title mob
might have been better animated a sack
on Titan might have been more compelling
Demon Slayer might have been more hype B
stars might have been more unique but I
know the tale told in Vinland saga will
stick with me for much longer I mean
it's already has this isn't the first
time I've got to experience this story
but that didn't make it hit any less
hard it's a story that's powerful and
raw brutal and grim yet somehow it's
beautiful culminating in one of the
greatest climaxes anime has ever seen
the series displays some of the best
character writing and developments you
could find in as diverse cast but even
so there was still one clear standouts
because 2019 was the year of ask a lot
ask a lot isn't just the antagonist of
the year ask a lad is the character of
the year and a contender for the whole
decade is not often you come across this
multifaceted character who is not only
compelling to watch but commands your
attention every second he's on-screen
exhuming the type of charisma that
doesn't just charm the people in the
story but yourself as well it says a lot
that a character you end up cheering for
laughing for crying for is this
manipulative scheming bastard who is
responsible for killing hundreds of
people innocent or not and purse
we ruined god knows how many more lives
every fiber of your being tells you that
you should hate this man and you end up
just loving him some people try living
as a hero only to see themselves
becoming the villain but here was a man
who chose to live as the villain who we
all saw became a hero this was the final
series I finished before the year ended
and I can't think of a better way to cap
off a fantastic year for anime so as
2020 now has fully come one last time
let's give it up for 2019
arrivederci
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video I
just want to give a quick thanks and
shout out to book Walker today for
sponsoring me a lot of the titles that
I've talked about today are available in
their store in both Mongol and white not
before in fact they've made a link with
all of the available titles that are on
their store that I've also talked about
today and this also just include the
title I chose for anime of the year
Finland saga and also a lot of the other
contenders and most of the ISA guys you
can find all of that by clicking on the
link in the description and don't forget
that you can use coupon code gig up for
five dollars off and with that says
thank you very much - Jared Norris save
them Abdullah
don't miss p8r top vdd in your life
Walter that's all and everyone else on
page one for helping to support me on
this month now if you watch the end of
my last video you learn that I said that
I wouldn't be making the gearing's video
and that's why I could put myself into
it and well that's why it's a bit like
this year I hope the way to worth it
because I'm really proud of it and it
was a hell of a lot of work but it was
actually really nice to work on it this
year and really being more relaxed not
so pressured to finish it on the New
Year's well I mean this videos later
we've just no change the last few years
but if you're an OG won't sure I mean
this is just back to the norm right as
this is my first video of the years I
just wanted to thank all of you who
supports me in 2019 and I hope I can
continue making
you enjoy throughout this entire next
year anyway I hope 2020 has treated you
well so far I didn't get up and I will
see you all next time